dans la dernière année j'ai appris que
mon adoption était en fait illégal je
m'appelle Anne-Marie je suis né au Chili
puis adopté au Québec en 1986 j'ai
vraiment eu une belle enfance et plein
d'opportunités c'est une série de
coïncidence qui m'ont emmené à découvrir
que je suis un des prêts de 25000 bébé
volés à la naissance dans un système de
trafic d'enfants orchestré par le
gouvernement chilien
[Musique]
les premiers headlines que j'ai vu ça a
été Niort Times Guardian j'ai ça a piqué
ma curiosité évidemment donc je suis
allé lire ça
j'ai trouvé le site ensuite de
chirurgien adoptease worldwide j'ai
écrit à l'organisme ces Maria qui m'a
répondu à ce moment-là on est en mars
2022 plusieurs mois on passait j'ai
finalement un courriel de mariage la
femme de l'organisme le courriel est
assez court
ça a été
ça a été un choc ma mère biologique
avait pas du tout mon
information ça y est arrivé à quelques
reprises d'arrêter des femmes dans la
rue qui avait plus ou moins l'âge de son
enfant à ce moment-là quand j'ai appris
ça mon premier réflexe a été genre je me
sens appeler ma mère
ma mère
elle était au courant de
du système qui était derrière les
adoptions elle a tout fait pour avoir un
enfant puis de s'assurer que cet enfant
là et tout ce qu'un enfant peut plus
souhaité avoir si elle était encore en
vie
à ce serait pas contente il y a eu ce
deuil familial là qui a été fait dans
les dernières années et là d'arriver
avec cette information là qui fait quand
même surprise c'est une famille non
seulement tu as une famille mais ils ont
jamais voulu te donner en adoption tu as
toujours eu une place dans cette
famille-là puis ça évidemment c'est venu
un peu checker les fondations de mon
identité est-ce que je suis québécoise
est-ce que je suis chilienne j'aurais dû
être chilienne j'aurais pas dû être si
je me souvenais un petit 48 heures à peu
près pour finalement faire le premier
appel sur zoom il y avait donc ma mère
biologique qui avait mon plus jeune
frère ma grande sœur on a tous deux la
différence il y avait les filles de mon
plus jeune frère évidemment c'était un
mix d'émotion il y avait tellement de me
voir que il me demandait quand est-ce
que j'allais aller au Chili
ok oui j'ai accepté de poursuivre ses
recherches là mais j'avais pas on dirait
je m'étais pas rendu au point où et
peut-être que eux ils vont vouloir
développer une relation avec toi j'ai eu
une mère ici j'étais pas à la recherche
d'une autre mère même si elle aimerait
ça que je l'appelle maman pour moi
malheureusement c'est encore une
étrangère
[Musique]
de sa part c'est difficile à dire aussi
quand je réfléchis à tout ça j'aimerais
ça pouvoir juste y aller librement et
aller les rencontrer
mais il y a plusieurs freins qui sont
activés pour me protéger j'imagine